I would now like to calculate the moment
of inertia of a uniform sphere and it
has a mass m and a radius R now I'm
going to look at three axes so I'll call
this the x axis the y axis and the z
axis and first let's calculate the
moment about the z axis so if I write
down our definition and I'm going to
calculate it about the center of mass so
the moment about the z axis how do we do
that well we take a mass element now I
have to be a little bit careful here
because if you think about what is our
perp for this mass element it's actually
x squared plus y squared squared so the
distance here because it's going in a
circle the radius of that circle is x
squared plus y squared so we have x
squared plus y squared and we're
integrating over the sphere now this
looks like a tough integral but let's
now look at what would the moment of
inertia be about the x axis well the
only difference here is I'm integrating
now first if it's rotating about this
axis and I had a my mass element instead
of x squared plus y squared about the z
axis it's y squared plus Z squared about
the x axis that's the perpendicular
distance and if I calculate the moment
of inertia about the y axis then same
argument I have Z squared plus x squared
now the beauty of this problem and in
physics when we talk about beauty we
often talk about symmetry is that by the
symmetry of the sphere all of these
moments are equal
and let's call that I see it now if I
add these three pieces together what do
I get
so if I add I see MC plus I see em X
plus I see em why I get three times the
moment about the center of the axis now
what happens when I add these three
integrals I get diem if you'll notice x
squared piers twice y squared peels
twice and Z squared appears twice so I
get 2 times x squared plus y squared
plus Z squared but x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared is the radius of
a small sphere of thickness dr and my
mass element now I have to integrate
over the sphere and so now our Masson if
DM is the volume density of this times
the volume now what is the volume
density well that's the total mass over
4/3 PI R cubed and what is the volume of
a sphere of radius R and thickness dr
that's 4 PI R squared
dr so if i put that into my expression
what I get let's just get rid of the
four pies and I get three M over R cubed
times R squared dr and so
our three ICM I have a factor to this
interval becomes two times DM times R
squared and the DM is three M R cubed R
squared D R times another R squared and
what are we integrating over our
variable from are these shells spherical
shells that were integrating outward go
from R equals zero to R equal capital R
notice that our three MS cancel and
we'll just write this as I see M equals
factor two times M over R cubed times
the integral of R the fourth dr from
zero to R and that's a simple integral
to do R to the fourth is R to the fifth
divided by five and so we get 2 over 5m
r v over r cubed and we conclude that
the moment of inertia about any of the
axes of the sear is 2/5 M R squared and
in this calculation it's a beautiful
example of how we use the symmetry of
the sphere to simplify very complicated
integrals